So I want to give you a few tips on how you can deal with, errors that, might
creep into your code. And here's a typical example. Have a look at the code on
the left. It does something wrong. See if you can figure it out, just by
looking at it. Well truth be told, I couldn't either when I saw it the first
time. So let's run it and see, how it behaves. Whoa, look at that, the numbers
are getting bigger and bigger. That's the bank account I want. But that's not
the program that I wanted. I wanted it to stop. When I've reached a million
dollars. It's gone way beyond that. This is getting crazy. I've been waiting
here for a long time, and the program just is not stopping. So the first
question is, how can I make it stop without buying a new computer? So let me
show you that first. You see that little barber pole icon here? What you do is
you right click on it, and then you select the one and only menu option to
reset the virtual machine. And now the program has been killed, and we can
figure out what went wrong.